the more that you invest in this journey
of being the more you realize the
fractured illusion of identity right the
attachments that you've made between
what you do and who you are and your
attention is really all that you have
how you direct it where you focus it
those are the most important decisions
that you make right at the clarity that
comes with being will allow you to
discard or bypass expenditures of your
time energy focus and work that are
moving away from the person that you're
working towards or that you aspire to be
so it is the being that clarifies what
is important and what is not such that
you can bring a presence and a
mindfulness to the doing you can still
do hard things and you know exactly the
way that you described it but you're
doing it with a level of intentionality
and an understanding that that that
doing is worthy of the being that you're
bringing to it